[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum thanks for joining me
ryan pleasure hey
uh ryan just had a big birthday i did
you did you're you turned 34
34 years old happy birthday again happy
birthday on youtube or uh write a review
of the show today and uh include ryan
you know at the end of a demographic
yeah uh this this episode is is
dedicated to my good buddy preston
preston christensen he was a
16 year old uh boy that i met at the
ronald mcdonald house i met him and his
mom and we became good friends and
you know i watched him go through chemo
and i watched him go through high and
lows and um ultimately uh cancer cancer
beat him and uh
uh it was it's been really tough and i
just wanted to say without getting
emotional
that uh he meant a lot to me and he made
me a better person and
he affected a lot of people uh in a good
way and so this this episode is
dedicated to preston
um
also if you want to follow us on the
instagram and twitter uh ryan how do
they do that uh they go to at
insideifypod on twitter at
insideablepodcast on facebook and
instagram that's exactly right yeah uh
please leave a review it really helps go
on youtube you can watch clips as well
and old episodes
you could also get really cool merch at
the inside of you online store and you
can get sun spin merch the band merch at
sunspin.com you could also book me
um for zooms and i'm on the cameo thing
all that and most importantly um patron
patreon is a wonderful uh thank god for
patron all my patrons have really
supported the podcast and give them back
in so many ways if you want to support
the podcast join patreon become a patron
of mine i'll message you right away it's
patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash
inside of you i really appreciate all
your love and all your support
we'll read the top tier patrons at the
end of the episode right now this is a
good buddy of mine steve agee um
stand-up comic
actor
uh he was in a band he was in a punk
band but you know him from suicide squad
peacemaker which is blowing up
and uh he deserves all of it he's such a
great guy and i just uh
you know when your friends get some
success that makes you happy it really
does and i always was always rooting for
this guy just such a
talented guy a treat to be around
and uh when peacemaker hit i just was
like
yes
it's so nice to see that yeah good
things happen to good people they do
so without further ado let's just do it
let's just i think you're going to
really find this episode interesting
even if you don't know steve agee uh let
me know what you think
let's get inside of steve agee it's my
point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you asked me about
the the thing an escape from new york
posters in my room
the thing in particular but yeah i
didn't even realize that was escape from
new york from the angle that i'm sitting
yeah and you're you're wondering how i
got it autographed
so i know oliver hudson which you know
kurt raised him kurt russell yeah
and uh
he was on the podcast and he made the
mistake of saying oh yeah i go do your
friends ever
ask for autographs he's like no
i go really they never ask you for
kurt's autograph for goldie
he's like no they don't i go
because why
do you do you want wanna go [ __ ] yeah if
you're asking he goes whatever you want
whatever you want how many things did
you have a monitor i had him sign the
thing escape from new york uh
what's the overboard with goldie
over yes
it's somewhere but it took a while it
took a while to get those like i had to
harass oliver for a while to get those i
felt kind of bad but i was like at the
end of the day i don't give a [ __ ] do
you have people sign your bobble heads
no i don't have that that would be that
if i got into that it's it'd be starting
to get weird yeah right rosenbaum's
having him sign bobbleheads yeah i
already think it's a lot you know people
that people think it's a little weird
that i get autographs i don't think it's
weird did you already have the posters
or did you buy them once you found out
you could get them so that one those two
i found out that he would sign them i
spent 350 on each of them original
posters i wanted the original they
looked like come on it's kurt russell
you got [ __ ] kurt russell up there
so anyway i like it and now you have it
and
then what
well you can get uh
what's his name to sign him now um john
carpenter john carpenter oh wouldn't
that be great i've been trying to get
him on the podcast you know john
no but you know
the guys in tenacious d um john kaneski
and john speicher
who are the backing band for tenacious
steve yeah i don't know them they they
they tour with john carpenter when he
does his music are you serious have you
seen that that's amazing no oh
he does all the hits
halloween escape from new york escape
from new york yeah boom boom yeah
that was so he just plays that those two
chords for an hour and a half boom boom
yeah and then the rest of the man just
wails and
they just whale yeah
oh my god aj steve agee uh you know what
i love i've known you for a while yeah
how long have i known you
probably since i met james uh probably
over at sean gunn's
sunday so probably
10 12 12 years something like that yeah
and talk about like someone who you've
gone from
i'd say rock bottom or low
low low sure you've been in low places
in your life and now boom
people would say oh look he's
overnight number one show in the world
is it the number one show in the world
it is yeah
wait a minute peacemaker on hbo max is
the number one show in the world now tv
show yeah
how does it feel
it's it it doesn't register no
james posted like a
you know a deadline clip of that and
i was like it doesn't feel like it's the
number one show because i'm still hiding
from covet in my house and
anytime i go out i'm wearing a mask so
it's not like anyone would recognize me
so it's like
okay
that's great i mean it's good we'll
hopefully get a second season so yeah i
don't know how we wouldn't do you want
to get recognized
are you looking forward but be honest
because a lot of actors like no no i
don't i like obscurity i don't i like
obscurity but every now and then if
someone
like if you go into a starbucks and you
buy coffee and
you know the guy will write dye beard on
your
there's a reference to peacemaker but if
they you know every now and then it's
like oh just because you know people are
watching the show yeah that's true i
mean
i mean it's it's crazy because you have
like worked in this business for a long
time i mean you've like you've done
stand-up yeah i mean you're a musician
which i've never seen you play
what do you play bass yeah
do you still play
sometimes i have all the stuff and i
just tink around in my office but you're
pretty good though you've been in bands
i have been in bands do you want to do
it again
i don't think so why
with bands you have to rely on other
people
true though i came to l.a to be in a
band i went to the musicians institute
to study theory so you're good i was
good
i think
i'm really rusty my fingers are weak and
you know
my fingers are weak um
but yeah i i came to la i was playing in
a band and once i got here i was like
jesus there's like
a trillion bands in l.a what was the
band called
the grazers the grazers yeah like where
did that come from
i don't know
i don't remember whose idea what we made
shirts that was like a a bull with a
ring in its nose you know like grazing
like a cow and you would play you'd play
out a lot our first gig ever was the
roxy or the whiskey were you nervous
no i was i think i was really cocky
really i was like these songs are
[ __ ] great let's
so when i was in college my roommate was
just
would just stick around at parties with
like a cover band with his friends who
were also in school with us
and then just like in the movie
the movie where tom hanks manages a band
that thing you do it's the thing you do
yeah so much like that where the drummer
breaks his you know
giovanni robisi breaks his wrist and
then
uh what's his name takes over as drummer
and then the band takes off
so their bass player broke his arm
and tim my roommate was like hey man you
want to get just come jam with us we we
usually rehearse on sunday and i was
like sure
and i went and we just started [ __ ]
around and we just started writing songs
like quick like punk like
two minutes later you like punk that was
kind of like the band kind of yeah yeah
like buzzcocks type of stuff um
and like in one day we wrote like four
or five just really dumb quick but fun
songs and i was like we should be
playing we should be playing what are we
doing here
i was like that fast that fast because
we had enough covers and then i was like
we should be playing somewhere
and so i went back to the dorm and i got
out the ellie weekly
and i started just looking
at clubs and calling clubs going jesus
leaving messages going hey uh my band
would love to play at your club and
most of the places did not call back the
first guy that called back was a guy
i'll never forget his name mike
giangreco
he was like a promoter or a booker right
he called me back he's like can you play
the whiskey uh in three weeks
i was like sure yeah
and then i called all the guys and i was
like well we have a show at the whiskey
and they were all like uh
what
and then it was like every day we
started rehearsing you just rehearsed
every day you got really tight in three
weeks more songs yeah
and what was the response his thing was
like can you get people to come to the
show right
still to this day i think that's the
thing
you go in there you have to bring x
amount of people to see your show and we
brought like every one of our friends
and it was packed and it was
and the guy was like yeah i booked the
the roxy too you want to do the like so
we were playing a bunch and it was
getting a name at all not really no just
playing and enjoying locally in
riverside we would a bunch of people
would come see us were you thinking this
was going somewhere
i was yeah i was like this is it i'm
going to be a rock star and then i moved
to la and i was like i'm never going to
be a rock star because you have to
you it's it's not just you it's like
you have to have it your
singer your guitar player your drum they
all have to have you know the motivation
to get up and
and these guys were all you know
tim went on to be a pastor our singer
the guitar player thomas became a nurse
she lives in like tennessee i think and
nate i think is a lawyer a drummer like
they all
had their own this was for fun
right and you you didn't think that way
no i was like i don't know what else i'm
going to do i was an art major i was
like how old are you at this point 21
and where'd you go to school
loma linda university it's in riverside
riverside
and i was like this beats
pretending to be a painter
and lie my way through painting class
trying to
you know right
justify the critiques of my paintings
which were horrible
i just did abstract because i was like i
can lie my way through this right but
you're a really good photographer you've
worked at that yeah but that wasn't
until
it came way in my 30s when right digital
became a thing i had no patience for
film yeah and you weren't
really acting to what 2007 or something
i had done some commercials in like
late 90s just a few
and you're more of a behind the scenes
guy yeah i worked in post-production
a kimmel you worked on kimmel that was
2003.
from 90s to like 2003 i was working
post-production on real world road rules
osborne's temptation island survivor joe
millionaire not survivor
um
but
tons of reality shows that that's how
well were you just doing behind the
scenes stuff like editing and like
assistant editing and
assistant story editing and logging
video tapes and did you hate it or did
you really like it
no i hated it but it's
it's one of those jobs you know it's
like the mob where it's like once you're
in
it's like
i'm sick of working on the osborne's i
know a guy that works on temptation
island i'm gonna go there really you can
just hop jump ship yeah yeah everyone
does it yeah they just get tired of
something and they move on to the next
reality show but when did you say
you know because at that point in your
life you're not really playing music as
much anymore right
and now you're working behind the scenes
were you thinking this is gonna be my
life working behind the scenes i still
didn't know man i was i was at
groundlings too i was taking classes at
groundlings in the mid and late 90s just
for fun
no i wanted to be on snl this was when
the band stuff was dying like i came to
la in 95
and
quickly the man just broke up and i was
the only one my girlfriend broke up with
me and i was just living in l.a by
myself didn't know anybody
and i started dating a girl who's taking
classes at the groundlings this was like
96 right and i went to a show and i was
like
what what this is what i should be doing
who did you see at the show do you
remember anybody who made it big
um i think
mindy sterling was in that show mindy
who you know is frau farbissna in the
austin powers movie right
um
i think mike
mike hitchcock who you would know from
like a bunch i do know that name yeah
you know but not like well
anybody like that
no in fact when i started taking classes
i remember one of my first classes the
teacher saying oh yeah like two of our
two of our own have just gone over to
snl and it was will ferrell and on a gas
star
or will federal and sherry
cherry terry yeah yeah so maybe all
three of them so you had i don't want to
say delusions of grandeur but like you
you thought you think you're gonna be a
rock star you're a bass player you're
like i am i i've got this you're you've
got a confidence you're cocky you say
you're cocky and now you're in
groundlings are you having that same
kind of cockiness that you're like i'm
going to [ __ ] be on snl or i'm going
to do this oh yeah i feel like most
people there's two types of people that
go to the groundlings once you are like
convinced they're going to be on snl i
want to go to snl that's it
you're not even thinking mad tv you're
like i'm going for snl now who wants to
go mad tv or
i mean at the time sure i would love to
or
people who are just trying to
come out of their shells or who are like
bosses at an office and they need to be
able to express themselves so they want
to
just kind of do improv so they can
think on their feet and
company meetings and stuff
i was like and i remember
when i was
like 18 or 19 i called the groundlings
office this is from riverside because i
knew
they had a bunch of people on snl who
were
from groundlings or second city
and i wasn't gonna go to chicago or
toronto so
i called the groundlings theater just
cold called him at like i was probably
19.
and a woman answered and she's like
groundlings theater and i go hey how do
i i want to be in your theater i want to
be in your company
she's like okay well um you have to sign
up for classes and and you start at the
beginner level and i did that i took it
i did too and she goes
and she's like so you there's four
levels of classes and i go
what
i go how much are these and she's like
like 250 dollars for
something like that and i go
oh so you guys are a scam
i literally i was like oh so you guys
are
scamming people out of their money i go
uh no thanks i can figure this out on my
own and i just hung up
and it wasn't to like
almost like eight or nine years later
that i went and i was like
oh yeah all these people they all had to
pay yeah lorraine newman went through
class the groundlings and like jesus
well she didn't go through she was a
founding member but like right you know
i just read something uh
in
judd apatow's book
he has a new book he read the old one
right what was that called sick sick in
the head yeah sicker in the head so i
got a preview and i was reading the will
farrell
uh interview and he just like
he was at usc and he was you know he
didn't really know what he said i'm
gonna try comedy
three years of groundlings snl yeah
for someone yeah and he had no fear
because his dad was like he's like you
know what i don't know i've never really
done comedy he's like well you know what
most people you'll probably fail at it
but so why not do it you know you'll
probably fail you'll find something else
to do so he figured [ __ ] it and that was
kind of his mentality yeah but what were
you doing were you ex were you thinking
i'm going to be somebody here so i never
had a plan all i knew was when i was
about
nine years old
i got for either
christmas or for my birthday they're
both fairly close
i got a transistor radio that had a mono
earplug and when my parents would make
me go to bed at night
i would listen to
kmet uh 94.7
which was the the rock station in
all of southern california they were
syndicated well now it's 94.
the way
no it used to be the [ __ ] and um i still
like him and sunday nights they had dr
demento
um
and i would lay in bed listening to dr
demento as a nine and ten-year-old kid
and it's how i was exposed to carlin to
weird al
to
cheech
just every aspect of comedy like from
parody songs to stand up to sketches it
was all there on dr demento
and
i wanted to
be a comedian and also i wanted to be an
actor and this was at like 10. i had i
knew that 10 and 11.
i just didn't know how to do it i was i
grew up in a
family where there were
there was nobody in the arts nobody was
funny
nobody
everyone was a doctor or
you know in business or something and i
i thought you had to be born into that
world and so i was like
just i never made a plan i just knew i
wanted to do it like john ritter was my
idol wow john ritter and uh george
carlin
that was it those were the gold
standards for me
and it wasn't until i got to la and i
was like
oh i can be in the ground legs i
i just have to go through classes and
prove myself and
that's it was really the groundlings in
the late 90s where i was like
i think i can actually
do what i wanted to do you know it's so
weird because knowing you
i don't think of you as someone back
then who is just so cocky because you're
such a humble dude you're so quiet
you're kind of you're just fun you're
smart people like to be around you i
think that's why you know your
friendship with james and all of us just
kind of blossomed yeah but i don't
picture this guy who's just like i'm
going to do that i'm going to be an
actor i'm going to i'm going to be
comedian i'm going to be a rock star i'm
going to like you were a bit of a
go-getter i did it very lazily like i
was explain
i had to
i wasn't actively going into these i was
like finding them like
you know i went to high school and then
when i graduated all my friends were
going to college i didn't want to go to
college my parents wanted me to all my
friends were there so i was like
i guess i got to go to college
and all my friends were at this place
loma linda university because they
wanted to be doctors it was primarily a
place where you study you know pre-med
right
and so i went
wanting to be a marine biologist i know
i'm all over the place dude
i wanted
i figured
since i don't know how to become an
actor or a comedian
i'll be a marine biologist because
i spent a lot of time
you know we had a cabin on catalina
island when i was a kid and so we would
boat back and forth i spent a lot of
time in the ocean
scuba diving snorkeling i was like i
could be a marine biologist
they don't have a program at loma linda
but i could go
get all my biology prerequisites and
then i can transfer to like long beach
state or something and you did that
initially i was a biology major my first
year of college
and i failed every single class
hard why
because
it's biology dude they don't start i was
like i wanted to swim with fish and like
hold on to a dolphin spin and get
dragged through the water that's what i
thought marine biology just go to the
aquarium for god's sake
i didn't know that you to do that [ __ ]
you have to start off
on the
cellular level of biology
i feel like they should start you off on
a larger level like this is a mammal it
breathes it has milk you know this is a
fish it you know right and then work
your way down as you
get older in school you
you can retain that kind of [ __ ] and you
figure okay i want to keep doing this i
want to learn the cellular stuff not
like here you go 18 year old
learn about mitochondria and cilia yes
silly i was just like
nope i checked out i i would sit and
look at the teacher talking and not
retain one [ __ ] word out of their
mouth
so what's going on i would sit and and
make jokes in my head i had a teacher
his name was jose
everyone called him by
i
in my head kept calling him hoes b
and i was like
i couldn't let go of comedy like and
i failed my first semester and then my
my best friend sam was at school there
and he was a photography major because
they had an art department
he's like dude just be an art major it's
[ __ ] easy he's like i've seen you
doodle and you've you know
and i was like yeah
i'll be an art major and so i just got
an art degree really was that easy it
was super easy to get an art degree yeah
the hardest part was i still had to do
like
basic classes you know like an english
class and
yeah stuff that so you got by
i got by it should have been four years
i did in like five or six years yeah i
did four and a half or something um yeah
but yeah but while i was in college
that's when the band thing happened it's
when my mom
gave me a clipping that she found in the
local paper of like open mic night for
stand-up comedy
your mom my mom she knew i loved comedy
she's like you should do this and you
did that and i did it
wait a minute so you she gives you this
little clip clipping yeah and they said
no five minutes is that what it was
something like five minutes yeah
something really cool like three to five
minutes it was super easy
it was super easy so i wrote up like
three to five minutes bullshitting my
way through it and i was like this was
great
it's an open mic there's not a ton of
people so i would just do that
once in a while i still didn't put
put it together that like oh if you do
this a bunch of times you get the
experience and you develop a voice and
you write more material and
you're a comedian like i didn't put that
together i was just like oh that was fun
i'll just do three to five minutes every
couple months
yeah
and then my mom also sent me a clipping
for auditions for a local
like the local theater company in
riverside was doing um a christmas carol
and i went my mom's like you should
audition for this
and i went i was like that was
terrifying to me
auditioning for a real audition actor
auditioning yeah i had no experience i
just show up at this theater
every stereotypical theater snob you can
imagine was there
and it's like
you know it's like local like community
theater people right
and uh i was given some sides
i don't even remember what i read for
and then
the director called me that night she's
like you were great
she goes i want
i i don't want you to do that part that
part was
she's like i want you to be jacob marley
who's like the first
he's like uh scrooge's dead partner yeah
it's a big part yeah that was my first
acting gig and i was like what year
98 or 99. and did you kill it
did you love it did you did you i loved
it i loved it you loved it you love
going on stage every day i love
interacting with the audience or could
you say that again
who's that it's siri i don't know why
she does this
siri shut up
hey siri shut up
by the way we didn't even say siri and
she just started talking by the way i
once said alexa was hitler a good man
and alexa said something in a kind of a
roundabout way
i mean it was kind of like really yeah
it was
but i'm sure it was a mistake
inside of you is brought to you by
wondering
um you know that show life is short with
justin long mm-hmm uh you know what i
like about this guy is when he talks to
people he's really he's interested
kind of like me
you know what i mean i'm interested in
people i'm interested in learning so i
think that you know if you listen to him
you'll realize that he's a sincere
person and i enjoy the show uh look how
do we make the most of our time here on
earth how do we bring meaning to our
life's work and what is the best emoji
to use when texting these are important
questions asked on the weekly interview
podcast life is short with justin long
in each episode actor justin long chats
with celebrities actors musicians
artists and more about how they get the
most out of life in recent episodes here
his conversations with severance actor
adam scott comedian nicole buyer and
prolific author mark epstein you'll get
the inside scoop on their careers and of
course learn their favorite emojis too
listen to life is short with justin long
on apple podcasts amazon music or you
can listen one week early and add free
by joining wondering plus in the wondery
app
inside of you is brought to you by
nissan
the future will be great
but today is just as incredible meet
nissan's most advanced lineup if you
can't get enough adrenaline there's the
all-new 400 hp nissan z or for your
off-road adventures check out the
all-terrain nissan frontier if you're
more of a spontaneous road trip type
person hop in the nissan pathfinder and
for something more electric there's the
stylish nissan aria so let's enjoy the
ride
2023 aria and z not yet available for
purchase expected availability this
spring for 2023z and this fall for 2023
aria
um
all right so you're doing this you do
the play you like it yeah you're done
with the band at this point
no i'm still doing this you're still
doing the band off now you're acting and
you're starting to do stand-up comedy
yeah so you're doing all these things
and you're having a good time but you're
not making a lot of money no no it's mo
and it's mostly band stuff and when i
first come to la i'm working at
starbucks
and then i start taking classes at the
groundlings that's that all the music
stuff stopped
and i had a teacher melanie graham
who was in the main company at the
groundlings amazing woman
she was like
you don't want to be working at
starbucks do you know it's like no
[ __ ] of course not but i got a bills
to pay she's like she was a writer on
the real world right a story editor and
she's like i can get you a job at buna
murray
it'll be like watching videotapes and
entering info and i was like yeah i'll
take it
and that's what got me into reality tv
and i would uh every now and then
through the groundlings get an audition
for like a commercial were you pretty
happy at this point were you uh yeah you
were it was a good part of your life
i met people at the groundlings that i'm
still super incredibly tight with people
who've
i've worked with now who um
are now like huge stars and like
we were just kids in our twenties who
are those people like maya rudolph and i
were in oh you're close with maya rooney
yeah maya and i were in classes i i have
a photo i'll show you of me and maya is
sitting on stage with the gorillas and
we look like
15 year olds we look like babies wow and
um yeah well forte was there when i was
there um
and you went through the whole program
i did the all the classes now you do all
there's a basic class and it's just
improv that's what i took then there's
an intermediate class which is just
improv then there's a writer's lab
which they teach you how to write
sketches and the writer's lab
at i think six to 12 weeks of doing it
you put on a show of the sketches you've
written
and then and you did that did that
great loved it mike mcdonald was my
teacher
he came from somewhere
different i should say mike yeah michael
mcdonald he was on mad tv
um
he was my teacher and then mindy
sterling was my advanced teacher
and
then for advance you do improv and
sketch comedy you write for six weeks to
a show right for six more weeks do a
show
and the groundlings main company members
have to come and watch both your shows
and then they vote like
yeah let's move them up to the sunday
company where you do shows every sunday
and okay i did not make it into the
sunday company and i didn't crushed
because you were in with all these
people they liked you you're friends
with them all you're working hard i was
working at the theater also at this
point i was working in the box office i
was videotaping shows i was
that theater was my life for like four
years do you know who rejected you
no but let me tell you this i don't know
if this is
this is how it happened but
so they have to vote on you
the only company members that can vote
are ones that have seen both the advance
shows
the night of our second show
there was a bomb threat on melrose
avenue and we had to cancel the show and
reschedule it for the next night
most of the company members couldn't
come the next night so
i think
only like two or three people voted on
our shows
and i think there were people that were
not thrilled with the fact that i was
a student but already hanging out with
everybody backstage and like
too familiar
that's what i think and you were crushed
crushed i had no other plans i was like
so what did what did you do from there i
mean what can you do at that point
i just kept working in reality tv but
the growling's kind of it was that was
over
it was done i mean i was couldn't you go
back and try again no no one was like
you've done the whole program there's no
need for you to do it again steve
sorry good luck because you asked
yeah i was just
crushed
mindy who called had to call me to tell
me i was the last person in the class
that she called because she was dreading
it called me crying she knew how [ __ ]
much it meant to me
and did you cry oh yeah yeah
i had to get off the phone really quick
because i didn't want her to hear me
great thank you yeah okay cool thanks
mindy hung up and i was like sobbing i
was like what do i the next day i woke
up and i was like
i can't go to the groundlings to hang
out or watch show what the [ __ ] do i do
so
i did show like my class
we did shows like on theater row on
santa monica boulevard like maya and
myself and so you'd still do shows
yeah but just not at the groundlings
but i think they really liked me there
and so every now and then they would do
these benefit shows at the groundlings
called the trash show
and
it was a show they do like once a year
all the all the proceeds would go to
repairs on the the theater and stuff
like that
and
the trash show it's called take out the
trash i think
is nothing but politically incorrect
sketch comedy the worst most
horror if you can imagine it it's 10
times worse than what you can imagine
like it wouldn't go today it wouldn't
fly today
i think they still do them it probably
offends a lot of people it would offend
a lot of people and most of the people
that went to these shows were just
students
like because they would find out they're
doing a trash show tickets are going on
sale tomorrow they'd sell out in like
two minutes so it was mostly students
right
um and i and they would let me come do
those shows so maya and i would write a
lot of
[ __ ] up sketches for that for those
shows right and that kind of kept me
going a little bit right but you
probably because i know you and i have
talked about this people take a sip of
your coffee okay thank you but i know
that we both you know we've had a little
depression in our lives sure anxiety in
our lives when did first depression or
anxiety start hitting you
high school high school you started
dealing with that yeah i got sent to
military school i got kicked out of high
school
and my parents didn't know what to do to
me dude with me or to me i added a
little taste for the booze in high
school i loved
when i was a freshman two seniors took
me out and got me drunk and it changed
my life it made me not shy
i talked to girls i would kiss girls i
was like alcohol is amazing
and i really took taboos and like i
became an alcoholic
i don't want to say alcohol holic
because i literally stopped
when i was like 18 or 19. it was like i
think i'm done
and i never had an urge really i just
knew that when i was
a teenager and shy and terrified of
talking to people
that got me through it but
i really
leaned heavily on it
and so my parents didn't know what to do
with me so they sent me to military
school
the school where they filmed taps
valley forge military academy
wayne pennsylvania
and um they straighten you up
straighten you out
you know
in high school i was i favored the booze
when i went to military school
you're subject to daily inspections
because it's like the military right
and so it became a lot easier to
hide drugs in your well so you started
doing drugs in military school yeah
mostly like weed and like mushrooms
right and you weren't powdering your
nose or anything no i tried all that
stuff but it i didn't like it
i liked hallucinogenics and we i left
weed and
you know hash
um
but uh i remember specifically one day
in military school i was walking down
the hallway in the dorm
two of my friends were wrestling they
were play wrestling and one of one of
the guys lifted up the other one off his
feet and they both fell backwards
and
one of the guys hid his head on the
corner of a cinderblock doorway and
split his head wide open
and i can still see it to this day in my
head like you know
barracks and stuff in the military it's
all that lime green
so i just remember the stark contrast of
bright red blood coming out of this
guy's head onto a lime green floor like
it is burned into my mind
and later that night i was
at dinner
and i was eating my food and all of a
sudden i couldn't swallow
like
and that's not uh a memory reflex that's
like an involuntary like
it's like breathing you shouldn't have
to think you don't think about
swallowing and all of a sudden i
couldn't swallow and i was trying to
make myself swallow and i couldn't i was
having what i later
years later figured out was a panic
attack it just that's how it manifests
and you think it was because that
triggered it seeing all the blood and
everything that's what triggered it i
think that that at 17 years old was the
first time i realized
oh i'm gonna die someday and it doesn't
matter if i'm
80 which i hope that's you know much
later i hope i die when i'm much later
but
i could die when i'm 17
and it
really kicked everything off for me as
far as
my big problem has always been uh panic
and anxiety disorder right
mixed with some depression and it
started there 17 years and so it worked
its way through so did you get did you
end up getting there go to therapy and
get on anything or you fought through it
not until i was 30. i didn't start
therapy
i thought i was losing my mind my whole
teenage in college i understand i
didn't know that this was common
my girlfriends didn't know that i had
this [ __ ] going on panic attacks because
i was really good at hiding it
um i once had a panic attack this was in
college
from a 30-minute flight from sacramento
to burbank with my girlfriend from her
parents house
and i climbed over the seats
as we were taking off
i was freaking out so i thought i was
having a heart attack
climbed over the seats my girlfriend's
like what are you doing i was like uh i
think i'm going to [ __ ] my pants
i i didn't have to take a [ __ ] did the
whole plane hear this
yeah but when you're having a panic
attack you don't you don't care about
anything and i just made a beeline right
to the bathroom and i stayed in the
bathroom the entire flight until i felt
us touched down and this the flight
attendants were like hey sir i was like
i cannot come out
and they can't make it did you say
you're having anxiety attack no because
i didn't know it was an anxiety i didn't
know it was i thought i was dying
and this was
happening all the time and you're 30
years old and still not understanding
what's going on at that point i was
about 24.
but this was going on
and then i remember talking to a friend
you know i had been at um house of pi's
this is like when i was like 29 or 30.
and uh what's house supplies it's that
restaurant on facebook
you know it's like a denny's right right
um
and i was with some friends having
dinner and i had a panic attack
and i immediately just and i never
explained it to my friends i would just
get up and leave and they'd be like uh
where are you going and i just i would
just
bolt
and later i'd be like oh i i uh
i forgot something in my car you know i
would just make up an excuse and it was
always believable
and um
and the next day i was at a friend's
house and i go
last night i go i was in this [ __ ]
restaurant i i thought i was dying
my heart was racing
and i started sweating and as soon as i
left the restaurant it stopped
he goes
uh yeah idiot that's a panic attack
and i go what
he goes that's a panic attack he goes i
get them all the time
i was like what
and then once i started talking about it
with him i immediately felt a lot better
and i started asking all my friends i
was like do you get panic attacks uh
yeah
how many of them had one yes
that does feel good when you know that
you're not alone oh
my god
i i hate that any of my friends have to
deal with it yep
i called you yeah yeah my anxiety but i
also
love that i'm not alone
you know what i mean and
and it wasn't till i was about in my 30s
and
i i i think i was 29 or 30 when i got
booted out of groundlings and
my girlfriend at the time was like you
got to go see a therapist
and i was like why i have the best life
i go i have great family i'm awesome my
parents are great i go it's just this
groundling thing
she's like go she's like i'm sick of
listening to you
complain about this
i did it to humor i went to a therapist
i made an appointment
i sit down in the chair i'm thinking
this is going to be [ __ ]
she comes in she's like hey steve and
i'm dr
so-and-so and
i'm like hey and she's like how do you
feel about all this i was like i think
it's pretty pointless
i got everything seems great you know
other than you know groundlings kicking
me out and
she goes what's your family like
i immediately just started bawling
like
what it literally i was just like
and it
i the hour went by so fast i was like
can we do another hour can we just keep
talking she's like no it doesn't work
that way just come back next week why
did you get so emotional i don't
remember but it was like
just somebody asking me about myself and
you know
me being forced to talk about [ __ ] like
was just opening a floodgate and i saw
this therapist for years and years and
years really helped you helped me
tremendously
didn't help with the panic attacks i
mean a little bit she gave me like
breathing exercises and stuff but
it was
it was
after i quit reality tv and i quit like
i had a panic attack in when i was
working on joe millionaire and i just
walked out of the office
never went back they were calling me
they're like hey are you coming back and
i just wouldn't answer the phone
i didn't leave my house i was living
with like three people in a house
didn't walk out my door for like
months i was too afraid
i would have panic attacks every time i
left
and one night i went to a 7 11 at three
in the morning
because if i had to leave to get food or
money i would do it in the middle of the
night because i didn't want to be around
crowds
and i remember going to a 7-eleven just
to get something to eat and i drove up
into the parking lot
and i look in
and there's one person in there shopping
and i couldn't get out of my car until
they left the building are you serious i
was so i and then i was like
oh i have a huge [ __ ] problem and i
started crying i called sarah silverman
who i had met you know a few years
earlier
and she's like dude
this is
completely normal she goes
no it's not no she goes millions of
people's oh yes
this is normal no everybody waits for
the last guy to leave the 7-eleven once
he's out you're that's good that's why
we all experience that no but i don't
understand she goes you're having a
panic attack she's like that's normal
she goes
you need medication she's like i think
she's like do you see a therapist i go
yeah she's like you need medication
and
she gave me the name of her doctor
and
took everything i had to drive in the
middle of the day to an office in
century city
and sit in there and talk to this woman
she prescribed me lexapro
and i started taking lexapro and it
helped a little tired for a few days but
within two weeks i was like
back going out doing stand-up changed
your life changed my life
this was like 2002 or two are you still
on lexapro yeah
spitting on it since then if it ain't
broke
don't fix it i i it's working so you
really don't get depressed all that much
i mean we all get depressed normal
depressed like
you know i'll get sad but she didn't
give you anything for the anxiety she
gave you things for the depression
lexapro is it's both it's for anxiety
disorder it is and depression okay i've
never taken that one yeah it's good wow
inside of you is brought to you by
shopify uh as you know i have a shopify
account the inside of you online store
it's fantastic i don't know what i would
do without these guys it's so easy to
check out analytics how you're doing how
different products are doing it's they
map it out so easily for you and it just
it helps me know oh wow i only have two
of these left in inventory oh i have uh
shopify i don't know what i would do
without them shopify gives entrepreneurs
the resources once reserved for big
business so upstarts startups and
established businesses alike can sell
everywhere synchronize online and
in-person sales and effortlessly stay
informed scaling your business is a
journey of endless possibility believe
me this podcast started selling you know
a couple of t-shirts maybe a mug and now
i have to it's a weekly job for me to go
on there and go wow i've got all these
people coming here because shopify truly
makes it easier i love how shopify has
the tools and resources that make it
easy for any business to succeed from
down the street to around the globe and
like mine shopify powers millions of
businesses from first sale to full scale
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram ticktalk pinterest
and more gain insights as you grow with
detailed reporting of conversion rates
profit margins and beyond more than a
store shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify just go
to shopify.com
inside all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
inside right now
shopify.com
slash
inside inside of you is brought to you
by better help better help online
therapy i can't tell you how many emails
or texts or messages i get
from people telling me that better help
is helping them
and i really love that i love
talking about something that works that
helps people that is a sponsor on the
podcast where we talk about mental
health
it's very important ryan's still with
better help i'm still a better help and
it's still
helping still helping help i like
hearing that you know people don't
always realize that physical symptoms
like headaches
teeth grinding even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about
doom scrolling sleeping too little
sleeping too much under eating
overeating stress shows up in all kinds
of ways and in a world that's telling
you to do more sleep less and grind all
the time here's your reminder to take
care of yourself to do less and maybe
try some therapy better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to ryan you like to see people i do i
think it helps i do too i like to see
the person i'm talking to but that's
just me if you don't feel like seeing a
face you don't have to you could also
text you could have you can do whatever
you want it's so much more affordable
than in-person therapy
trust me on that one uh going in
in person therapy is is so expensive
it's i'd say some cases it's triple
quadruple the cost of better health by
far uh you could be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see if online therapy can help
lower your stress i believe it really
can truly this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and inside of you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash
in sign give therapy a shot
better help online therapy
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance well of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowner's condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
so so sarah silverman got you saved my
life saved your life you also did a show
with career-wise and
emotionally career-wise why did you why
did sarah silverman save your career
after i had quit
after i quit reality tv i didn't know
what to do i didn't want to go back to
working in a coffee shop
um
sarah and i had gotten on medication
sarah called me one day and said jimmy
she was dating jimmy kimmel at the time
she's like jimmy's doing
a talk show now
she goes they they don't even have a
name for this position but they need
someone to do research
to just watch tv and find funny clips
from to make fun of in the monologue
i was like i'll take that
i'll sit in an office and watch tv for
10 hours a day so i did that
that was kind of miserable just because
you're watching
you're watching the view you're watching
uh the 700 club tv you wouldn't watch if
yes you're looking for funny things to
make fun of you know uh
um
you know home shopping network stuff
like that right
that's what i was doing it was driving
me crazy i couldn't watch tv when i got
home at night because i just didn't want
to
but i stuck around because i wanted to
be a writer i was like
i think i can be a writer
and i let jimmy know and
as soon as there was an opening like he
made me a writer like he was the best
wow he seems like a good guy
i don't think we had a very similar
sense of humor i think i was probably on
my way to being fired
you know i would pitch a lot of stuff
dark
yeah or just like
really
out there like
out just like weird
weird sketch ideas and stuff and he's
like
no
and i think i was on my way to being
fired
um but then sarah got her
the sarah woman program yeah her pilot
for comedy central she wrote a part for
me
that happened and i
quit jimmy's show
um
you know all on good terms i still love
jimmy he's the best and um how long did
you do the sarasota program for
from like
2007 i think we shot the pilot in
we got picked up early 2007 i think and
we shot until like 2010. wow so it was a
pretty good run like three seasons yeah
and you got paid a lot of money
no comedy central they don't panic the
worst the worst money they don't pay
anything
but
i was able to make a living you know and
make a show with all my friends i was
friends with all those people through
sarah already and it was
that's my first like acting real acting
job and i was like oh this is easy
really i'll just do a show with your
friends yeah okay
i mean that's the life isn't it then
when it ended it's like
well i guess i'm a character actor and
i'll do an occasional
you know
episode of new girl and stuff
what you did which i did and i did it
for years and years i mean it's how much
of a struggle is that being a character
actor kind of because you were sort of
like for a while dependent on your next
job like you were it wasn't like you
were sitting there with riches going oh
i don't have to worry for three years
you were thinking like i can get by for
another two months yes
and it was
i did all right at it as a character
actor um because a lot of those jobs
turned into recurring parts
you know like i had a recurring part on
new girl
um
you're the worst superstore um speech
there was a point
not
not too long ago where i was recurring
on like
four or five different shows so i do
three episodes of super store three
episodes of new girl
a couple episodes of a year of the war
so it was like it was pretty good for a
couple of years you know right i mean
were you at this point
happy
would you say yeah yeah
you were yeah yeah
because you hit a lull after that right
yeah peaks and valleys there were there
would be times where it was like
i'm glad i'm living in an apartment with
low rent because
this is getting
a little dicey right and then you'd
yeah you'd do like
10 episodes of you know three different
shows you'd be like oh i guess i'm good
for
the rest of this did you have it did you
have an agent who stuck with you for all
these years
or did you kind of bounce around i had a
i have a manager that i've been with for
quite a while and she's been great and
she's
you know she's left different places
that she's been with and i've always
gone with her and i'm still with her and
she's great
you know you you did
what was the guardians galaxy 2 james
castro and guardians galaxy 2. so you
were we did we did i was in that too
yeah we were we were in that together we
were also in the movie hit and run
together yeah
no scenes together though those scenes
together
puts me in like everything and it's but
it's always like
the mechanic you're the idiot who comes
in and says one dumb thing and as he
drives away and it's hot rod
right right
but you know there you go yeah uh i
appreciate it so what was that like did
you have to audition for guardians or
james just say hey you want to play this
character no he's just like
it's a small part it's you're a ravager
james likes to work with his friends as
you know you know he's
you know he may not always cast his
friends as like big huge parts but like
he he'll fill a movie with like
his friends in smaller parts here and
there and it's i just remember being on
set
of guardians 2 and you're doing some
scene and he was like ag
do it like this say it like this and
you're screaming and you're young and
he's just adding he's trying to find
funny stuff that you can do extra things
that you can do
to just i think when we were doing
guardians 2
when dailies would go out to like
kevin feige and them i don't even know
if that's how that would work but they
would see footage and
they liked you they were like these guys
were really funny so
i was supposed to die in that movie you
know the scene at the end where where
michael rooker kills everybody with zero
yeah
and so we did that much later like i
shot most of my stuff when we did the
stuff with you
and then i came back like three months
later to shoot just my death scene
and we shot it and then james was like
i would shoot something else
just to make
just have footage so in case we want to
you're still alive
and so we just shoot a really quick
scene of me on the ground crying
that i've been stabbed and my beer has
exploded and that was it just to have
you know in case he wanted to use me
again doesn't that feel good though
feels great it feels great right he was
going to do it in a a a post-credits
scene you know how he had like three or
four
scenes during the credits
but he was just like that didn't make
sense man yeah so he used my scene
and the end credits yeah yeah
now from there he casts you
in suicide squad
yeah now you have a part you play the
same character that you do in peacemaker
right is it the same character
john economist john economist who comes
up with the name economist well john
ostrander came out he's an actual comic
book character he is yeah well i should
know that people are probably screaming
at me right now john ostrander came to
set
um to visit
and james introduced me he's like he's
like steve this is john astre and he
created the suicide squad
and i was like oh my god
it's great to meet you and
james is like steve's playing um
he's is that my
no it's not your watch it's my cuckoo
clock i got so scared embarrassed no
don't be embarrassed i should be
embarrassed he goes steve's doing motion
capture for king shark and he's doing
john economist
and
he looks at me he's like oh you look
like the real john economist
and james and i were both like what and
he goes oh yeah he's like i based the
comic character off a friend of mine
i was like oh so there was a real guy
named john economist do you think that
helped you in um
him casting you in peacemaker
yeah maybe because the part
john economist is not a big part in
suicide squad that's very nice
one dimensional you got kind of a one
line here one line there yeah and
you know you're doing that and you're
also standing in for king shark yeah now
how hard is it to stand first of all
being a stand-in alone i see how many
hours they're on their feet how
exhausting is it to be a stand-in for
king shark it wasn't
it technically wasn't stand-in it was
motion capture um
[Music]
they had a stand-in that would when they
were lighting and stuff there was a guy
i wish i could remember his name he was
great he would stan big dude who would
stand there
but i was just like i was there for
reference so the actors had somebody to
look at
and i could do you know scenes with them
and uh it was actually a blast i would i
hope to god they use king shark
you know if there's no if there's not
another peacemaker
that would be amazing but if there's not
another suicide squad movie you know the
characters at least now in the dc
world and you know were you uh
being considered to voice king shark at
first in the beginning no it was when
james asked me about it because i read
for it many times he was james was like
i
he's like i want you to do what shawn
does for rocket you know he's sean's
right right right right motion capture
he's like i want you to do that for king
shark he's like i need somebody funny
he's like i need someone big and i'm
like james's tallest friend so it just
made sense
it was never brought up
me doing the voice we never even talked
about it in fact we did the table read
and at the table read
we'd never discussed what his voice was
and it wasn't until we were starting and
i'm sitting there with like
idris on one side and margot robbie on
the other and i was like super nervous
and i
as my first line is coming up with i was
like
i don't know i don't know what this
[ __ ] guy sounds like
and so i did it like
me read i did it like ominous and deep
and scary and which works because he's a
big shark right
and so after
then once we started rehearsals james
was like that's not working
he's like
he's like he's just a big goofy
english isn't his first language he's
kind of slow he
and then at one point he goes he's like
think stallone he's like like like a
slower down version of stallone like
stallone but trying to find the words
and i was like
me
so i was doing an impression my
impression of stallone the whole time
he didn't know they were going to use
stallone but
i knew i was like
you know especially towards the end
peter saffron was like just so you know
they're they're reaching out to people
to you know audition for the voice i was
like
yeah i figured i gotta go yeah
um
but in my head i was like
why don't they offer it to stallone
because it's a million dollar role that
that's probably what they were
considering is like this is expensive
but but it's also dc and it's also james
gunn and he knocked it out of the park
with guardians so i think dc is like
exactly we gotta trust this guy so
i was never shocked that it was stallone
i
i remem you know i met him when we did
that stuff on guardians but there's no
way he would remember me
but i met him at the premiere for
suicide squad and i just [ __ ] walked
right up to him i'm like sly i go i go
i'm steve i did all the motion capture
for
king shark he's like oh my god he's
doing it that must have been rough
running around he's like you did a great
job
i posed for some photos with him and i
was like that was awesome that is
awesome so when did you get the call
from james saying i want you to be this
character john economist i want you to
bring him back and peacemaker is that
what happened that was
i didn't know james was doing it
nobody knew james had like
quarantined down time lockdown you know
he just started writing it he wrote
eight episodes in eight weeks
he just to write
and then he went to warner brothers and
said hey i had this idea for a spin-off
for tv
and of course they were like yes okay
we'll take it let's do it
we'll do the eight episodes and
while they were figuring all that out i
guess he was probably fine tuning it and
it wasn't until
october of 2020
that
he called me he's like i didn't want to
get your hopes up but he's like but
we're going to do a spin-off of suicide
squad so you you'll your agents will
probably be getting a call soon i was
like what
but you didn't know how big it was gonna
be right
i knew it would be bigger he's he's like
you're you're gonna be a serious regular
in it
and i was like did you [ __ ] your pants
for so many reasons yeah
one of just like flattered that he would
do this for me
two
there's a global pandemic nobody's
working at this point it's still the
first year of the pandemic
so i was happy to have work you know i
had been living out of a suitcase and
you know i didn't find
a place to live once i got back from
shooting suicide squad because the
pandemic started so i was like living on
friends couches
so i was like oh my gosh well you also
had a really rough year you lost your
mom my mom died two months into the
pandemics two months in the pandemic and
you were very close with it that was
incredibly rough yeah yeah she and not
kovitz she died of leukemia like she was
diagnosed just before the pandemic
so she went fast two months two months
after she was diagnosed two two and a
half hours how [ __ ] shocked and like
didn't even
hit me that that was that could be a
thing but yeah
i mean how do you how did you deal with
that did you because you were alone
during the pandemic you're alone you
lose your mom i get back
we literally wrapped suicide squad in
panama end of february i had two weeks
of visiting my mom in the hospital every
day while she was doing chemo
um
and then the lockdown happened and the
hospital was like you can't come and
visit her anymore
and i was like
what am i supposed to do i was going to
be using all that time to find a place
to live but my mom got cancer
so i had nowhere to live
um i call my friend dave out in joshua
tree who's got like a small
i remember cabin basically he's like
yeah you can stay here
and so i was
isolated in the middle of the desert
calling my mom every day on the phone
and listening to her deteriorate and get
more and more confused she got to a
point where she was just like
i think they call it chemo brain where
she's just like
not making sense it's almost like
dementia or in the saddest part of all
of it was she's like how come you're not
visiting me
and i was just like [ __ ]
i was like mom there's a pandemic
they won't let me in the hospital and
she'd snap out of him she'd be like oh
my god she's like that's right yeah i
forgot right two minutes later same
phone call
why aren't you visiting me
yeah so the hardest part of all that was
knowing that
she passed away alone in the hospital
and be
confused as to why she was alone and her
family so that killed me for like a year
yeah you know
um and then two months later my friend
lynn died
much younger
not much older than me and lynn who was
talking me through you know facetiming
me every day after my mom died talking
me through it then lynn dies
and they find out
she died of the same thing that killed
my mom like she was just undiagnosed
lynn was dating marc maron
and they were living together during the
pandemic and then she got up one morning
collapsed
they took her away to the hospital that
night she was dead
and it was leukemia i remember that and
it was just like another like just
and i was just like
so the first half of 2020
first half all of 2020 yeah was [ __ ]
horrible
and then james calls me in october and
he's like we're doing
peacemaker and i was like and you were
rock bottom at this point at this point
this is the lowest you've been since
you've given me this is
the worst year of my life 2020. and then
james like completely
pulls me out of like a [ __ ] pit
and he's like yeah i was like all right
when are we doing it he's like in three
months
wow and i was just like good get me the
[ __ ] out of here
and that was seven months of getting to
hang out with james and jen and
cena and a lot of work
yeah pretty exhausting
at times but it was it's an ensemble so
and they would block shoot episodes so
it'd be like
there'd be like two weeks where they're
doing all this stuff at a prison and i'm
in none of those scenes so it'd be like
just driving around british columbia
taking photos right you know yeah you
can look on his instagram and a lot of
those photos that are still there at
steve agee at steve agee um
you know i watched the first four how
many have aired at this point well i
don't know but they will have all aired
by this point
yes six just one this airs
um
i was so
happy
to see how good you were oh thanks man
because you know your friends you work
with your friends and i always think oh
steve's hilarious i love being around
steve steve's a great guy i love him you
know he's a character actor i only see
him one line at a time and now i see you
and it's like you're going toe-to-toe
there's some scenes with you and and
see i almost said joe spina but uh
cena
let's just start calling cena or
spinacina spinach coke cena and josie
but seeing you in these scenes it's just
like and it's not one-dimensional
it's like you could see this character
kind of hurt at times yeah physically as
asthma falling against the wall and like
you know being abused and like getting
emotional getting hurt his feelings hurt
casinos throwing [ __ ] at him peacemakers
making fun of him his beard being died
yeah wait till the finale dude i don't
say anything no i'm not saying anything
but like there's just a full arc like
it's a great character i'm so lucky
i owe james
a lot but you nailed it thanks man you
nailed it and it's just it's so fitting
sometimes like you know there's so many
great actors around but it takes that
right role for people to go oh
you know what i mean to realize how good
they are yeah because a lot of times
you're only as good as the writing
you're only as good as
the product it's also a character that i
that i relate to a guy who's
you know can be the butt of people's
jokes and is just like doesn't want to
go outside of his comfort zone i'm very
comfortable at home at the computer like
like
economist is at his computer that's
where he's doing his best but
you know i long to go out and be
adventurous and you know economist gets
to go out and
kill things and people and shoot you're
my favorite moment it's one of my
favorite moments and it's such a nuanced
little thing it's the first time you
kill someone or you think you killed
someone oh yeah yeah remember yeah and
you hit him with this pipe yeah and then
repeatedly and then you for the first
time but you kind of run away a little
bit because you're all you're scared
yeah because you're thinking yeah he
might come back and get you beat the
[ __ ] out of cena like i'm like yeah he
could deny it and then you keep beating
him you're like yeah yeah and you're
just so excited about this and you just
really kicked out john economist
[ __ ] john economist [ __ ]
yeah um this is uh
these are some questions this is called
[ __ ] talking with steve aj these are my
patrons oh okay lovely patrons who
helped the podcast uh in so many ways
great patreon.com inside of you if you
want to uh help the podcast are these
insiders is that what you call them
would i call them patrons okay i could
call them insiders
why haven't you
i'm gonna write that down
thanks for listening insiders we got a
new episode leanne what is your dream
role or project next to peacemaker
i mean that's
it literally is
what i'm doing right now i i can't
imagine i would love to do a western
i would love to see can you do a country
accent well southern well [ __ ] man i i
think i could [ __ ] do it you know i
think i [ __ ] you could do it awesome
just [ __ ] some [ __ ] i'll shoot
some [ __ ] i would love to do a
western i'd love to do a war movie the
thing is i'm in my 50s now i'd have to
be like a colonel or like i couldn't be
like
saving private ryan like a young recruit
that's all right colonels or colonels
could be cool but i'd love to do a war
movie emily asks what was your favorite
outside dave moment from new girl
um
probably actually
this my outside dave's second episode
cause usually outside dave is like
he's the button at the end of a scene i
i would never work for more than two
hours on an episode of that show but
there was one episode where i'm in the
whole episode
um
and
it was directed by uh by lynn my friend
lynn who is my friend who passed away
last year that's when i met lynn
lynn shelton
that was my favorite outside day because
it was like it was a big part it and it
was
he was supposed to just be one episode
and they liked him and they brought him
back and this was his first time
back as a recurring character awesome
dana s
when you bombed on stage for the first
time
she was there what
how did she know what did you do were
you prepared for the bomb no nope
i
this is great because i had done a show
we were doing sarah silverman's show
program the sarah silverman's program
and
she because of the show she would do a
lot of college gigs you know like pretty
big like theater college gigs
we did a show in stanford and i would go
and open i
my first time opening for her was in
stanford
and she was like you want to come open
for me i was like she goes you have to
do 20 minutes and i go
i i have i can do five minutes and she's
like
she's just going out and [ __ ] oh she
goes no you have all these dumb little
short films that you make at home she's
like put them on a dvd and we'll just
you come out and introduce them and talk
about them and that'll be 20 minutes i
was like oh yeah okay
so we go to stanford
and
we're walking into a 2000 seat theater i
am immediately have diarrhea i'm so
terrified i've had diarrhea from that
and
and the the the house manager is like
showing us back to the green room and i
go who would i give this dvd to
uh to show some stuff and they go oh we
don't have a dvd player
and sarah just starts laughing
and she's like you better think of some
[ __ ] to say
and i was just like
so we go and we're like there two hours
early and sarah's just
on her phone and on her computer and
not worried about and i am sitting in
the corner like going um what's funny
what can i talk about and what and i go
out on stage
in front of 2000 people
i don't bomb i go out and i start just
riffing like making fun there's nuns
sitting in the front row i start talking
about them everyone is dying because i'm
on tv and they've seen me on sarah's
show like yeah it's the guy from so
they're laughing anything i say
is hilarious
and you don't think you're that funny
no and i'm like now i'm like super cocky
i i can't go to sleep that night i was
on such a high the next night i have a
show at the improv here on melrose and
i'm like
i know this is going to be [ __ ] easy
like that was 2 000 people in probably
what 200 people maybe
i go in there
walk out on stage say the exact same
thing i wish i could remember what it
was that i did up at sarah's show
silence
silence silence
luckily no one was heckling but it was
silence i go
they must not watch the show
i'll go on and i say the next
joke or whatever
[ __ ] silence
boom flop sweat i am now it just like
that covered in sweat
i'm like
short of breath do they know this i
don't know they know you're struggling
they probably don't
they could probably see me sweating but
i i probably don't look scared but i
sped through
what the night before i did in 20
minutes i sped through it in like
maybe seven minutes
and i was off i was off the stage and i
was like
wow that was that was the worst thing
i've ever done did you never want to go
on stage again i didn't for a long time
i was like oh i need to write more
i can't do this it's i'm not robin it's
terrifying you really have to work at it
yeah it is absolutely terrifying even
like when you're doing really well and
then you say a joke and then it doesn't
land
even one joke after you're killing it
can just throw you just
um
yeah and doing 20 minutes 25 i've done
25 minutes before and i only had done it
for like yeah yeah it just it's
i can't explain it it's it is terrifying
i always feel like i'm not kidding
and not to be graphic but i had i take
like 10 shits before i go on oh yeah and
i'm like when will this go away and
swartzen's like never you'll [ __ ]
forever i did a tour with tignotaro and
it was like taking martha kelly from
baskets and
we were just driving around up the west
coast you know to washington and down we
were just doing
all sorts of shows but we were doing
shows that we booked on
myspace
and we were doing shows at people's
houses
people would hit us up and we'd come to
their house pass around a bucket for
tips and they paid
gas money some of them paid
we made enough to get to the next gig
right
and we coined a term uh diarrhea arrival
which is
you drive up to a house and you see
the conditions that you're going to be
performing with and you immediately just
have diarrhea because you're like this
is going to be [ __ ] horrible
so diarrhea arrival was born diarrhea
arrival
oh man well i'm just so happy that you
know things took off for you because
it's it's you know there's so many
talented people there there's so many
talent people out there and you're like
when are they gonna get their shot i was
i just had uh lunch with jason alexander
they name drop yeah and he was just
talking about that he's like there's so
many i mean it's really a lucky thing
because he's like a dime a dozen for
people that are talented yeah but to
have that moment you know well this is
my first series regular since sarah's
show
ended in 2010. i'm 52.
i should have given up a lot of time
you know yeah i mean but you have been
working i haven't been working
there's been lean times but i've made a
living as an actor do you think you
would have kept going even if
you didn't get to offer this show
yeah yeah yeah you kept going yeah even
during the pandemic all this [ __ ]
happening you think you still would have
risen to the occasion yeah rose to the
equation
risen to the occasion
risen to the occasion i rose
did you rose to the re creations
rose to the and bound
uh this was a real treat for me me too
man did you have fun i had a blast this
wasn't i didn't honestly this is one of
the first things i really didn't know
what i was going to talk about but i
knew you'd come oh there there would
never be
dead air between us yes yeah tell the
audience what you recently sent me a
picture of
i don't remember what i said it came out
of your penis i'll give you a hint oh
my kidney stone or the stent what was
that
explain what a stent is so i
it looked like i've had kidney stones
off and on since you know my my 30s
and um
but i've passed all of them
no problem i really you know just on my
own
drinking water when i know i have one i
chug water and it flushes it out
i had one that was so large two years
ago that they had to do surgery to get
it out they're like we're gonna go
through your penis with a camera and
laser
we will find it pinpoint it and break it
up with the laser and then we pull it
out with this little basket
and um
and then we leave a stent in your ureter
the ureter is
the tube
oh there it is
can you see that's the stent it's the
size of an iphone charging cable that
was inside of my body
and they leave it in your ureter
because
put it up on the patreon
somebody can zoom look how horrified i
look you can send it to jason for b-roll
that's two and a half feet long curly
cues on the end to keep it from falling
and they numb your penis so it didn't
hurt when i took it out no it just feels
awkward but that it that goes in so your
ureter doesn't swell shut from the
trauma of the surgery
and keep you from being able to pee they
say passing a kidney stone is equivalent
to maybe delivering a child right or
nothing for me no it wasn't bad for you
i have a high pain threshold i
when i get a kidney stone when it starts
to pass
oftentimes i'll drive to the hospital in
case it gets bad
but i can usually just stay in the
parking lot and just kind of walk it off
chug water but i want to be near the
emergency room just in case
yeah hey real quick who's uh who makes
you laugh harder than anybody else on
set who's the one that can break you
um
cena cena can break you yeah yeah
he's broken you before yeah yeah freddie
does too freddy who plays vigilante also
james
james will
throw [ __ ] we get to points where he
starts throwing out
alternative lines alt lines
and some of the stuff is so funny i
can't
get through it the first time because
i'm hearing it for the first time i
haven't prepared who's the most
professional on the set
jen is really professional and so
well jen danielle and chakuti who plays
mern
the three of them are like just pro
flawless yeah
you love it you enjoy it
it makes you better you know you've
worked with people like you've worked
with walking and oh yeah
it makes you better it always makes you
better yeah
what a treat well i hope you get many
more seasons to come you deserve it
fingers crossed i love you
love you too man i really thanks for
having me thanks for coming over you've
been doing a lot of press for peacemaker
guys make sure you watch the peacemaker
it's on hbo max follow steve aj he's a
hilarious guy you're going to love it if
you haven't seen this you're going to
love please john
economist economist
honestly hilarious just just wait a
couple episodes in until he starts
getting really fiery and barking back at
cena's character that's right that's
right we all have our breaking point we
all have her what was that from i don't
know we'll have our breaking point was
that point break
no
it wasn't definitely not all right
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
you today thanks mike
you liked this episode i did he was a
good guy yeah he's uh he just tells it
how it is you can just tell that this
guy's been through a lot
and he just toughs it out and is that
the right word touches it out a lot of
different chapters in his life a lot of
different challenges yeah yeah
and it's like wow he's in his 50s now
yeah
right
and boom
he gets a role that finally makes people
go whoa
hey
that guy yeah it's amazing how one role
can change change your life and i think
peacemaker really did and i hope it
continues for him so steve thanks for
coming on the podcast thanks for
divulging so much information to
ryan and i uh if you really like the
podcast i urge you to continue listening
um i think you'll enjoy other guests go
on youtube
leave a review leave a review on apple
spotify
also i will be at the
uh i'll be in st louis at a con
may 13th weekend we're doing the
smallville nights in st louis with tom
willing which is a two-man show we
improvise and we read scripts from
smallville and uh so i'm gonna be there
and then i go to liverpool on the tour
for the 21st that weekend of may um and
then june 10th and 11th i'll be in
metropolis illinois and then the 16th or
17th i'll be off to australia supernova
so join me at one of these places at
least for the love of god come on
you could do it meet up with me
uh also the inside you online store is
available for merch and sunspin.com for
band merch um and zooming me and there's
cameo there's all that stuff
um
i appreciate you but most importantly
thank you all my patrons
um
join patreon um it's a way to get back
to the podcast if you're digging it go
to patreon.com inside of you become a
patron these are the top tier patrons
that i read every episode because
they're so supportive and they give a
little bit extra to the show which
really freaking helps ryan
helps me
yeah helps me
helps everybody yeah happy birthday
again man
thank you 34 years old yep
um got a lot of years left ahead of you
man a lot of good years i could feel it
yeah i have some really good years
coming up
thank you i feel that i feel it yeah i
absolutely feel it for you
well thank you yeah yeah let's just uh
let's just keep living l-i-v-i-n
g
uh i'm going to the beach this weekend
if you want to join we're going saturday
a group of us nice yeah so if you're
around all right let me know here are
the top tier patrons i'll read them off
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa ukico
jill e bryan h nico p robert b jason w
kristen k allison l raj c joshua d c j
peace jennifer n stacy l jen s jamal f
janelle b kimberly
uh e correct mike e eldon sopremo 99
more ramirez santiago m chad w liam p
janine r maya p matty s belinda n chris
h dave h spiderman chase sheila g brad d
ray h tabitha t
damn boy
tom n liliana a talia m betsy d chad l
rochelle marion megkay travel dan n big
stevie w correct angel m rhiannon c cory
key k key
super sam dev
nixon correct michelle a jeremy c andy t
give yourself some kudos
cody r gavinator david c john b brandy d
uh vore camille asked the
c joey m willie f david h adelaide n
omar l omar i
lena n design otg eugene and leah
chris p nikki g cory nicole patricia
heather l jake b james b bobett able f
joshua b tony g
megan t mel s orlando c john b caroline
r rob e paul c christine s sarah s eric
h spring and jennifer r those are the
top tier patrons they give back quite a
bit to the show and they uh top tiers
receive uh boxes from me of merch and a
little note every couple of months and
there's other tiers that you can join if
you just want to support the podcast so
patreon.com inside of you uh um got a
great episode coming up next week so i
hope you guys will stick around um get
anything going on ryan you want to talk
about just the birthday uh
that's kind of it man just been thinking
about aging in life
wait to get to be 50 buddy oh can't wait
you know what it is it's like here's my
way of kind of rationalizing and sort of
just
putting things into perspective
when you're 50 you think
why was i worried about getting old when
i was 40.
when you're 60 you're going to be i'm
going to be like god why don't i just
enjoy my 50s i was still young
you just got to enjoy it it all comes
down to just
being present and just being like hey
you're 34 right now you're not even
mid-30s you're below the mid
so
it's the end of uh
being marketed towards as a young person
it's the 18 to 34 demographic yeah
i'm like a parent
i'm like you are also a parent with two
p's
a parent
did i do that
oh i thought i did i was trying to do a
homonym
homonym homonym what's a homonym it's
when two words look the same but sound
but sound the same but look different
look the same with sound different like
a space parent or you're an a parent and
you're also a parent you're also
yeah like principal yeah principal
a principal at the school principal yeah
having principles yeah is the hominem
the right word is it a homonym let us
know let us know anyway uh guys thank
you for uh
making us your choice for podcast we may
not have you know every week you might
not know a guest but i think you're
going to learn something and you'll
enjoy it so we hope you stick around
thank you very much i am michael
rosenbaum i'm bryan
hills in hollywood california california
i'll give a little wave ryan we love you
and thank you be sure to be kind to
yourself be good to yourself thank you
for allowing me to be inside of each and
every one of you it's a real treat
and
hopefully you'll keep coming back and
i'll keep coming back all right take
care
[Music]